welcome to this video playing mandragora
Grandmaster she bluffed home thailand so
let's see okay let's do something simple
I'm playing really it looked good in the
last couple of games I want a simple
position so why not why not this and see
what is coming up with quick Bishop g4
hmm interesting considering to take no I
don't think so
yeah I won this is long castle it's an
idea I don't think so really with a
knight on f6 so i can probably just
castle shorty m and what I'm wondering
is okay this is probably a useful move
in any case yeah whatever you can say
about this it's a it's easy to play not
not ambitious I know but at least it
gives you some assurance that you're not
doing anything stupid like I did in the
last couple of games is there some way
to do anything I mean
maybe trying to get rid of this pin yeah
it's 95 is this something that leads
anywhere no idea but okay maybe it
probably it shouldn't be bad really if I
take with the rock and threatening
Bishop f6 at least and this bishop on h5
is also a bit but maybe it's not i'm not
expecting to be a bit better here but
maybe I'm a little bit quicker on the
e-file okay and now if I take and rookie
one that did this faucet the Sun I'm
cookie i click on the EVO
tightening Bishop f6 winning a piece
there is some pressure here or isn't it
Bishop f8 Bishop f6 is also winning a
piece Bishop d6 maybe should be six but
I can take f6 take F 60 k f6 Bishop b5
Bishop b5 f6 and he is getting the piece
back so Bishop t6 is probably the move
yeah okay is there some way to exploit
this looks it looks a bit shaky TIG is
seven queen a three this kind of
business and it's not leading to much
now my night is not not playing here hmm
oh it looks a bit looks a bit fishy i
wonder if i should take actually here at
least he is forced to check with the
pawn my but that's not leading to
anything really it is really just equal
yeah okay so i can take f6 now and take
the age whatever that might accomplish
the take f6 it takes a five bishop jakes
and sets let's good yeah so G takes
semaine de to check check okay if i know
its rate we have he has two doubled
pawns it shouldn't really very black
still I wonder can I do do something a
possibility is was to get in g4 h4 h5
okay at least f4 is on a dark square now
okay you can go to h4 this is really
accomplishing anything
hi 1f h 4 is a move I might go all the
way to a 5 you might do that
so that's something that I can do here I
mean I can i really just shuffle Queen
over I can always try to enter with this
King a 5s is ever a good idea a five
night before yeah I'm thinking too much
here probably when there is nothing to
do now he goes over to the Queen side
I'm not really worried
I can put the key on b3 and just sit
down
you can place you form okay now it gets
tricky with the time but this is Sir
this is all of a sudden not so bad right
I know I'm suddenly something better not
not much or any chocolate no my night I
just blend of the night Wow game yeah
that's probably the fair result of all
this I haha i blundered the night at one
point in there in the end game it
probably just is a draw the whole time I
mean you just write you to do something
and I think maybe he should go see for
some time but I can go to be form yeah
this is after that i'm suddenly better
and i really should win but i made a
very stupid movie with with the check
King obviously here here I went here if
you can just take it you can just take
it if i go here i'm winning the game
please 625 and i'm picking up g6 and
when we're just promoting even I can do
this young because of the the fork trick
yeah I why this white is winning quite
quite simply him yeah this was a this
was a real draw all the way I thought
that around here it looked like I maybe
have something computer gives Bishop f4
that sets a tricky move and Tandy maybe
rupees 7 Bishop d6 after that I don't
have anything am pretty check check yeah
yeah I made some some little mistakes
here really this for example I mean okay
not a big deal the night is ok on d3 of
course but maybe I should start with
this to make sure he's not getting b5
and would have been would have been
interesting f3 I wanted to go g4 maybe
g3 first yeah this is this this this
this could be could be better and yeah
the night is a should be the slightly
better minor piece yeah but nothing that
should should lead to we know anything
here here it's really equal we tried a
bit and I have was was getting somewhat
messy at the end but it's it's very dry
okay thanks for watching